[Musique]
allez coeur certains les vénère donc ce
les graver sur la peau mais dès que les
choeurs sont au menu
le doute s'installe plus coeur se mange
moi j'aime tous les abats moi tout ce
qui est bon ce qui se mange en mange
il existe une véritable histoire d'amour
entre le chef philippe de vienne et les
plats à base de coeur c'est délicieux
puis c'est une critique peas et pour
compliquer un peu pareil philippe
recommande d'acheter les quarts chez le
boucher ou directement du producteur est
douce et la nettoyer
c'est pas difficile il faut savoir
comment parfois ya une petite peau
dessus on joue de la pop alors là qu'on
célèbre liqueur de vaud l'accord paraît
aujourd'hui essentiellement il reçoit
une grosse veine qui dépasse on peut la
manger des gens ne préfère ne pas
l'avoir alors on la coupe il ya souvent
beaucoup de gras sur le dessus du coeur
donc on peut donner un petit coup de
coude ont enlevé l'excellente gras et il
faut ensuite les dégorger puisqu'il y
avoir du sang l'intérieur alors la mère
de dégorger ce soit on les met dans
l'eau vinaigrée quelques minutes pour
les fraudes bien pour faire sortir le
sien qui pourra bordeaux dans le coeur
il ne faut pas l'oublier c'est un muscle
au même titre que la chair de poulet ou
de boeuf
si donc été extrêmement maigres à aucun
grand mais à l'intérieur c'est notre est
très maigre solide et si on voit saler
poivrer houleux dans la farine qui
démarre sur une assiette a le coeur sur
les goûteuses on peut seraient des
enseignements qui sont plus corsé ok on
généreux sur le poisson médaillon
medline c'est un peu le secret est-ce
qu'il ya quand même des techniques de
base qui font respecter pour les
allocutions des cas mais si on cite le
coeur ce mu qui peut se servir saignant
ou médium saignant bérenx une cuisson
rapide à chaleur élevée sur grillé soit
sauter soit pour aller ou alors
carrément brésil jeté pendant longtemps
alors on arrive au pouvoir ont des
glaces avec le porto
ça va des flammes dans la soirée
c'est en branle une gorgée de vin garder
son amoureux ça des blogueuses un coin
de l'oeil pilotera regarder la poire on
met un peu beaucoup de crème comme on
veut c'est tellement bon c'est tellement
nourrissant et coûte rien c'est vraiment
la viande très économique
et voilà selon l'animal ses choeurs se
vendent entre 4 et 7 $ le kilo
ça vaut la peine de laisser rosé pour
que ce soit juste comme ça cela que les
pendre c'est vraiment bon c'est goûteux
mais c'est pas phares comme ghoul chez
les gens on part s'ils ont une image ou
un goût des fouets trop cuit de leur
enfance avant les couverts puis de
goûter les yeux fermés plus vraiment
évolué ce que dans la bouche parce que
c'est pas du tout ce qu'on s'imagine les
coeurs de canard sont encore plus simple
à nettoyer si vous voulez vous pouvez
enlever le surplus de gras vous coupez
ensuite l'écart en deux vous les rincer
dans l'eau et ils sont prêts pour une
marinade et d'inspiration coréenne
soleil à huile de sésame et pas de
fermenter coréenne tout ce qui nous
reste à faire c'est un brochet sauter de
guerriers puisqu'une petite dernière des
cinq dans la garniture oignons verts
sont soya sirop d'érable et graines de
sésame
au moment de servir mon copain julienne
une poire asiatiques et on a des
feuilles de laitue parce qu'on se faire
des petits wap l'assaisonnement et
parfait la viande est tendre juteuse
puis on goûte à canards honnêtement
quelqu'un qui serait pas que c'est
décapant serait que c'est un morceau y
en a trois
[Musique]
si lakers ont plutôt délaissé en
amérique du nord ailleurs c'est une
toute autre histoire
c'est tellement prisé partout sur la
planète c'est parmi les morceaux les
plus chers en chine les chinois sont
très forts faire sauter les choeurs de
volaille quelques selon dans l'huile
très chaude il faire exploser karimun le
reste de l'asie où siègent les corps y
est les japonais dans les bars et
history le coeur des brochettes de coeur
ça se mange ou andy barlow steak cela au
pérou les coeurs de boeuf sont un
véritable délice sous l'appellation un
petit coup de chaud dans ce restaurant
terrifiait de verdun les brochettes sont
sur le menu
depuis plusieurs années puis je pourrai
plus en vue de la carte
ricardo om les antiques ou de choses
c'est son père à augusto qui lui a
montré à cuisiner c'est tabac 6 po
petits coeurs de boeuf plus difficile à
trouver
le coeur de boeuf s'achètent souvent
congelés une nuit au réfrigérateur et on
peut ensuite le pari si ce n'est pas
déjà fait richy fait prêt à cooper ont
fait des bandes qu'on veut pas se
tailler en escalopes ça peut quand même
des morceaux assez épais d'un centimètre
à peu près le pouvoir pour contrôler de
la cuisson
pour la marinade on mélange purée d'ail
origan paprika cumin vinaigre de vin
rouge huile et ceci alors on utilise les
acquis pancarte
c'est un piment péruvien et c'est chez
nous on fait raid raté puis on en fait
une purée alors on a pris ça du commerce
qui était déjà fait leur voix m les
claires de brefs à parrainer de la moi
je conseille au moins quatre heures de
marinade au pérou c'est quelque chose
qu'on mange tous les jours depuis qu'on
est jeune ça vient
la cuisine de rue ça vient des africains
la cuisine créole comme on dit que les
africains qui sont venus ils rapporté
ben bayatt lina maintenant nous on fait
traditionnellement à chapeau en bois sur
un barbecue on les gens y viennent
manger seul le soir après être sortie
des discothèques des clubs ils vont
rencontrer la petite madame qui au coin
de la rue en train de vendre c'est un
petit coup de chaud puis en revanche et
avec du maïs puis des pommes de terre
s'étendre
ces deux labels à vos amis vous dites à
certaines ska dub puis vous aime encore
ouais ils reviennent me demande une
fugue simple c'est quoi si le coeur vous
en dit succombez à votre tour au charme
de cuisine et les caves
[Musique]